let's talk about us us I'm worried about
us are we in US I've never thought of
this isn't us exactly since you've been
here you've made friends that's great
but we haven't spent much time together
because at work you're my boss and at
home you're my dad and everybody else is
just a normal friend yes so let's go
somewhere where we're not father son or
boss employee
just friends oh my God are you gonna
make me jump out of an airplane strapped
face to face with you again because that
was terrible well I loved it and I'm the
one who got vomited on
you guys this is my new favorite show
that was Rob Lowe in the Netflix series
unstable which he stars with his real
life son so let's just get him out
Rob would you do the honors oh yes
please welcome my very own mildly
talented son
[Applause]
oh my God that's happening with me and
Olive now oh yeah they hate it when you
love on them still yeah they don't like
and I get to do it all the time for that
intro that was very sweet of you wasn't
it yeah I thought you'd like that so
your guys's sense of humor in real life
and in this show so it started with like
was it tweets was it like you were
taking your dad down like on social
media like the humor got public and then
it sparked
yeah I mean it started technically
before social media I've always given
him a hard time because
it's very easy too uh and then yeah when
social media came to be he continued to
be his his uh you know ridiculous self
and uh he you make it so so easy like
you post these layups where it's like a
shirtless selfie in front of his Emmy
nominations and I'm like why'd you frame
it like that man like why is that
because that's the wall in the gym no
there's four walls
something wrong even though the Emmys
that is such BS I know that's not true I
know that's not true and you do post a
lot of thirst traps for a 59 year old
man I don't even know what a thirst trap
is that's that's impossible uh you we we
know the thirst traps it's true you
Shadow and you couldn't be more right I
mean let's just show one you know just
but yep there we go okay but you're in
it yeah
but then because John Owen is so funny
you followed it up with this
well that's the same photo
exactly but with just John stamos's head
how did the John Stamos thing start he
does that to our Christmas cards I do
he won't stop
I mean we all love it we think it's
hilarious well then we don't want you to
stop in fact
I have a little surprise for you
hi guys hey Rob hey Johnny hi Drew I
love you uh Johnny the bit about me
being your dad this is funny and uh you
know people get a good kick out of it
but it's getting a bit old
um I'm just I'm tired of trying to
explain that you're no I'm not really
his dad I'm a better looking version you
know so um uh Drew if it's okay with you
uh Johnny and I did a 23andMe test and
I'd like to read the results live on
your show and and stop this madness if
that's okay so what
you know what I don't need to prove
anything
good luck uh with the show guys burn
this take it burn it
let's burn it
that's amazing all right so did your dad
dress up in like a Sasquatch costume or
something at one point we were on a
family camping trip we were so young and
it was such an accurate costume and it
was in the middle of the night and he
scared us so badly I was crying in I ran
to like the RV and was crying and my
other my cousin threw up he was so
scared he's vomiting it's true I love
that now
um Switching gears a little bit you guys
have supported each other in amazing
things you know and I've been really
honest with my kids who are younger you
know but I they know they know my story
they know I you know can't drink like
it's just not for me it doesn't work for
me they know my pitfalls and you guys
are an incredible family unit that
support each other through every high
and low everything well it we do and we
share to be able to share recovery you
know you you you're in recovery I've I'm
in recovery got 33 years in recovery
Johnny
[Applause]
five years in fact I Johnny's five-year
birthday
and Johnny I want to give you your
five-year chip
[Applause]
proud of you buddy
speechless that's um I usually have a
witty retort I don't have one for that
that was very nice of you
I can't do this show because I'm smiling
too hard Rob I think you're gonna have
to take us out again should we like get
on the floor and roll around for a
second that's what we do here please I'm
watching please please
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]